CBS News has learned former president
Donald Trump's legal team has turned
over additional classified material
which was discovered last month at his
Mar-A-Lago home this development comes
as FBI agents find another classified
document during a planned search of
former vice president Mike Pence's
Indiana home Pence who is mulling over
his own presidential bid may have to
testify against his former boss he's
been subpoenaed by the justice
department special counsel investigating
Trump's alleged effort to overturn the
2020 election results
Robert Costa has more on this
local police blocked the driveway
leading to the Penn's family home as FBI
officials conducted an exhaustive
five-hour search leaving with one
document with classified markings and
six additional Pages Pence and his
family were traveling in California his
team fully cooperated with the search
which came weeks after around 12
classified documents were found in the
residence last month the former vice
president who is considering a 2024
presidential bid told CBS in early
January he took no classified documents
when leaving office there were no
classified
materials that that left the White House
or remained in our possession but Days
Later a personal aide did find documents
in his home mistakes were made
and I take full responsibility for pens
it's just the latest interaction with
the justice department special counsel
Jack Smith investigating former
president Trump's efforts to overturn
the election wants to hear from Pence
under oath about the pressure campaign
he faced from Trump and I hope Mike is
going to do the right thing I hope so
Trump's Relentless pleas for Pence to
block the certification of the election
and his refusal to do so spark Fury
among some Trump supporters on January
6.
[Music]
the president's words and actions
in and around January 6 were Reckless of
interest to the special counsel sources
said his Pence has reportedly intense
meeting with Trump in the Oval Office on
the eve of the capital attack when Trump
was trying to cling to power but it's
unclear how exactly Pence will handle
the special counsel subpoena and whether
Trump will try to block Pence's
potential testimony by citing executive
privilege when it comes to private
discussions and it's worth noting that
Pence's top eight have already both
cooperated with the Justice Department's
investigation into January 6. and
sources tell us Pence's team is now
waiting to see whether former president
Trump will try to block the former vice
president from doing the same for CBS
Saturday morning Robert Costa Washington